sprechen wir noch etwas über den
wahlkampf in den usa über corona über
trump john kornblumen der frühere
us-botschafter in deutschland ist mir
zugeschaltet schön dass sie sich zeit
genommen haben
herr kornblum wie geht s donald trump am
sie informationen über den
gesundheitszustand des us präsidenten
naja es gibt verschiedene quellen es
gibt zuerst die erste und da muss man
annehmen dass sie ein schönes bild
versuchen ein schönes bild zu gehen ein
bild das nicht recht ist dann gibt es
die berichte in den zeitungen und das
ist natürlich sehr sehr groß und im
grunde sehr skeptisch über den
gesundheitszustand aber dann gibt es
auch die wörter und auch das handeln von
selber und ich würde sagen
diese letzte kategorie ist das was
sozusagen zweifeln lässt
gestern habe einen sehr hektischen und
ein wirbel sage passiere zu den tag
gehabt getriggert über verschiedene
dinge vor allem hat er gesagt bekommen
ist gar nicht so wichtig wie man meint
man muss total verbleiben und weil das
alles da überwinden
das hat zu einer sehr schlechten
reaktionen der bevölkerung geführt und
dann noch viel wichtiger ist er hat
plötzlich am nachmittag die
verhandlungen nur eine erweiterung des
wirtschaftspaket das paket das die
menschen finanziell unterstützt menschen
die arbeitslos betroffen sind alle
einfach stornieren abgesagt und auch auf
fast auf befehl ist es ist die börse in
die tiefe
und es gab eine gewisse panik am
nachmittag
später am tag als limitiert aber mir
gesagt hast
dass er nicht vor in besitz der
kapazitäten wie wir sagen aber ich und
das ist doch noch zweifel geben muss wie
es hingeht und muss es auch zweifel
geben am nächsten tv duell zwischen
beiden und trump am 15 oktober soll das
ja stattfinden glauben sie dass es
stattfinden wird
ich persönlich glaube dass es nicht
stattfindet nicht weil das nicht will
und auch den fall meinen dass nehmen
würde für beiden ist das wie wir sagen
nein winwin situation aber ich habe das
gefühl dass sein gesundheitszustand
nicht halb so gut ist wie er angibt und
das erhöhe begrenzt in der lage sein
wird diese debatte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren